marvin Ambrosius thanks for coming on
the show man oh thank you so much for
having me you are famous in the fitness
industry I'd say I'm the understated
famous person what does that even mean
it's like you've got you're on a media
channel to where you've got a television
show you've got millions of people
watching it but in a social media world
I'm really not known but you know what
though you've met everyone I've been
very fortunate living so many different
lives through music basketball working
in fact I sky television doing
television show yeah and then yourself
as well which is funny enough working
with you I bumped into quite a few
people or a few celebrities yeah exactly
which you weren't even expecting and
it's like it's just a crazy world yeah
that's it right you'll work in like
pretty much full-time but I do it anyway
of Commerce because it sounds like
full-time attitude oh yeah beautiful
being around and available full-time but
we work out every day
everything you help me with my meals you
help me lose a stone last man exactly
dude I can't burn it that mean I'm still
a little I've got quite a long way to go
but we literally started the grand
scheme of things if you look at a
12-month period and you look at a stone
in a month that wasn't even by us doing
a fad diet
it wasn't juicing it was literally
behavioral change you got to eat
properly you got to enjoy your food yeah
and you got to Train that's how we means
amazing with the fitness industry like
in business I know things do take time
so a business like I've just like I just
sold six houses this morning I guess of
six houses this morning and we're
talking about it might take a couple few
months to go through yeah so my mind
done the sale done took me two or three
votes that's fine but they're actually
two and three months whilst I don't
think that's a long time when I'm
thinking in terms of health it could be
two or three days and I'm annoyed I've
not lost anyway he's not actually hold
on a minute let's just think let's be a
bit realistic apply the business acronym
yeah to our fitness and that's exactly
why I'll be honest it's been a pleasure
working with you
yes you've discovered that very early in
our training yeah you've literally
realized that looking at a scale every
day isn't gonna change anything
what is gonna change something is wheel
it to the scale every two weeks every
three weeks there's gonna be a massive
change just this is the same references
of the contracts yeah you know if you're
gonna do an exchange I've sold the house
well you've sold it but once the
contracts go through once the money is
exchanged that's when you know it's done
and that does take a few months as you
said yeah weight loss fitness lifestyle
exactly the same what do you stand for
in the health and fitness industry what
are you represent realistic be
measurable and achievable that's what I
stand for I'm all about making sure it's
part of your lifestyle make sure it's
fun and make sure it's sustainable I
don't believe in anything that you do
that can happen quickly and then it can
disappear even faster it's funny because
I don't know I think you've even changed
me a little bit as a person in terms of
and I'm not even talking health I'm able
to be fit that's like even as a trainer
like the way that I train now I almost
feel like is has been Marvin eyes I'll
be honest that's the first time anyone's
ever Marvin and I've got that we're
keeping it you look you invert that in
common I was okay when you're training
me it's fun I want to not impress but
like I care what you think
yeah don't disappoint so if I never have
if I have like a bad meal right you're
not going to be you don't love yeah I
would have any go at me but all fear
just a little bit like you know that's
that's to do with approach in
relationship yeah you know even though
while I train I feel like I'm more even
more loving now tomorrow's my students
interest in your debate you had with
Piers Morgan you won't debate him
because Piers Morgan was saying that fat
shaming is a good thing because people
need to be and what I can see is point a
little bit yeah you're very much you
saying no yeah you're very like kind but
you still get result yeah and that's the
reason why that's my philosophy I'm like
if I can get results without doing that
why am I gonna make someone feel bad and
get results because all I'm doing then
is creating a negative space to get
something positive I don't see how
that's even positive how can a negative
and a positive make positive positive in
a positive make a positive yeah you know
what because I feel like I do think that
the first step to change is a
oh yeah and if your engine oil written
as a fireman says if I'm if I'm if I'm
sat with someone and I'm teaching them
about property I'll have to become
financially free yeah if their minds say
is so broken yeah and their bank is so
broken in there but they're saying no
I'm comfortable okay I'm actually you
know what you're really not only you're
not broke and you need help and that's
kind of what that awareness but I feel
like we've waited if you're fat you kind
of know you're fat well yeah if you
don't need to be told you it's a
personal thing you know it and you don't
need other people going around telling
you you are yeah you personally know it
and here's the Westway I'll give you an
example let's say you've started this
fitness journey right now you've been a
month in you've lost the stone what if
tomorrow someone comes up to you and
goes you factor that you should do
something about your weight
well to be honest you've been doing
something about but how did that person
know so many people are on fitness
journeys and by having that negative
comment it can either enhance you to
want to get there quicker or make you
feel less area to the situation so I
always say you're supposed to empower
people to want to change not to make
belittle them to me I want to see I've
got some friends and they dread their
personal training sessions like
literally dread them so they'll say oh
and I got a personal training session in
the morning and then it's like a black
cloud and I just I just haven't got that
with you I look forward to them and if
we skip a day I'm like oh man I missed I
missed the session that to me that just
lets me know that for everything up in
practice in teaching for years that's
exactly what I want I want people to
look forward to having me not being
dependent on me but being a point to
where they feel responsible that they
know that if mom's not with me today
what would mom say yeah what would Marv
do what would he say in this situation
and we're at that point now where you've
actually messaged me and say I'm at this
restaurant I've got a business mean this
is what I'm eating is that okay and I'm
like dude that's fine that's absolutely
fine you've picking the right meals
because I'm actually in your head now
we're there yeah we're at the point now
where we're linked
and we understand in order to move
forward we have to take a step back and
really assess what we're doing and that
took you a month it takes people months
we're talking like sometimes three to
six months to get to that stage but
that's down to your mental fitness I
think one of the things I've learned
from you is rather than being obsessed
with the result you got to fall in love
with the process exactly and that is the
same with anything in business rather
than me I want a million pounds in my
bank and focusing on that like crazy
just actually what do I need to do
what's the process to get there and I'm
gonna have to fall in love we're doing
that yeah because like you said there's
a journey to everything that you're
doing and if you were let's say if I
became a multi-millionaire but the way I
got there I hated it how would I be able
to teach someone else how to do the best
practice to get there you can't teach it
yeah what you've done is you've enjoyed
your process seen all the stages of
winning losing failure success and what
you're doing is you're teaching people
this is what can happen this is what
can't happen but best of all this is how
you can do the process and love it and
on top of it become financially free I
mean when you came for your not
interview but like when oh yeah yeah
yeah what was that two hours
yeah like look that was really weird
because you said you'd spoken to people
prior to me which I didn't know and you
said it was like 5-10 minutes go to
session for some people it was 20
seconds for me I walk into I'll pop my
head in hey yo what's up man good to see
our walkout was with you I was like oh
you know I knew within two minutes that
I wanted to work with you it was it
always became law I was selling you on
the idea
you actually got at one point I remember
you said to me like why I'm offering you
a job right now what's the problem yeah
I was like I'm not used to this I'm used
to basically getting to the point of
this is what I can do for you but at
this point you were solved yeah and I
wasn't selling myself I just saying to
you this is what I would provide and I
remember saying mister you know and you
I've got other commitments and I said
well what can I do to help you leave
those other commitments yeah we do right
now but because it was right on the spot
I didn't go into the meeting was the
agenda of being asked that question yeah
then what was really good about that now
I go to everything with that in mind I
go on that mindset of
like what if someone asked you at this
moment I want you to leave this this and
that and I want you to work for me now
how would you respond because that's
never happened to me before so I just
fall okay I took two steps back in the
meet and I said I'll have to get back to
you but if I did this is what it would
look like yeah and we spoke about and
that's why our conversation was even
longer but then I'd realize that wait so
that you like come on do it but at a
time but then what's crazy is I'd
realize wait a second I'm gonna be
review for what five days a week for a
year if we don't like each other yeah
wait what is like you're horrible what
and I was like this is quite scary and
then I'd realize that let's have a few
conversations but after that two-hour
meeting
I pretty much and strolling you in line
as well that was good a ghost in ghostly
already a ghost of you I then realized
that okay this guy's all energy energy
energy
what am i energy energy energy you can't
get nothing but positive from that it's
funny as well because I remember you
when I was saying to you you know I was
trying to convince you to come and work
full-time for me with me I kind of feel
like I work for you in a way because the
other person that tells me what to do
yes but but I remember yeah we're
talking for money and stuff and use him
woman it's not that important to me I
was cursing you out he's no important
you've cause it's important to you guys
yeah and and weird a conversation and
then when I talked about some of the
stuff the money can bring you like maybe
money is kind of gravity it's kind of a
boy because when I said it's not
important we were talking more about the
job satisfaction silent yeah yeah I
think at that time I'd created a space
for me where everything that I was doing
I was enjoying and that was the first
time ever I have got to that point and
then all of a sudden very went and I was
just like wait a second is there there's
a rift in the matrix right now I'm
enjoying everything do I take a risk but
then I was like is this a risk I might
know this is growth this is development
this is actually doing something that's
never been done before what made you say
yes to working with me full-time I'll be
honest with you you're very persuasive
man and you did have some you had
certain key things that you'd said where
you
know me well enough to know what ticked
my personal boxes yeah cuz I have my own
ticks and you tick them I just I just
actually just took everything if it
wasn't one of the boxes it's no yeah
there was there was definitely some like
if that was in there then a no I was
like but you you'd mentioned and said
everything in a way that made me go at
the end of this whole year it's not the
end of the year this is the start of a
relationship this is a start of
something working with the company and
over basically offloading my ideas and
how I actually believe in fitness and
what I feel like I can bring to your
company because it wasn't just about use
about the company because I've given the
whole company a fitness workout plan now
yeah and everybody's everyone's doing it
they're enjoying it they can call me at
any time and then I'm helping them out
and it's just nice to be involved with a
great team of people because that was
another thing you introduced me to the
whole office
you didn't have to do that and everybody
embraced me everyone's talking I was
like I really like this environment this
is pretty cool and after a while I was
just kind of a case let's let's just do
this and you know we're not just doing
it we're winning yeah and it's funny as
well because I think one of your fears
was that if you cancel all your
commitments or you oh yeah and then
after a month I'm like you know what I
don't like you anymore or not even I
don't like you anymore but I've actually
lost motivation I'm not really
interested in losing way I'm good then
you're going to be left with nothing
with nothing so but I was like you know
what let's tell the world then let's get
you on the podcast homeboy yeah exactly
let's do it not only will I be letting
you down I'll be laying everybody down
yeah and if my perspective the the peer
pressure from not being able to counsel
you yeah means because if I counseled
you now if I was like I you know how
much anyone counseled you then not only
would that be bad on you but it would be
also make me look bad in front of
thousands of people that are watching
and I'm sure you'd ever think or to to
say do you know I'm not that guy though
I know I mean even so there's a low
people that will just go I can't believe
I'm like you know what that's personal
so I just go I know I come up to you I
know where you live on the other side
obvious out of the gate like my side
dude I'm climbing over you know what
though but my point is that the positive
peer pressure of making yourself
accountable not only to and I'm not only
careful to you
but my wife is in on it my manager
Emilia is in on it she organizes
everything on it the whole team office
everything else go what's this all about
but I'm not only that but we've included
the whole social media tour my suits and
my fans like everyone's in on it so for
me it's almost like I've forced myself
to create an whole new environment
around health and fitness because before
I was relying on my own willpower you
know I'm gonna do this I'm gonna get up
early and I'm gonna go through a run I'm
gonna eat healthy but then soon as soon
as III lost that motivation or was
destructive or speculative changes now I
can't do that because Martin not i but
my environment is different yeah and my
friends and colleagues and staff Eddie's
different so it was like for me I don't
really see I could never go back to be
in junk not working that it wouldn't
happen if I if I counselor work out if
you if something you you can run the
number and I've disappeared in I'm off I
know that you will find me that day I
will you will hold me down I'll be I'll
be viewing the property in Liverpool and
then I'll just say I've counseled
meetings in the morning with you I mean
I can't make out man I've got I've got a
oh shoot early jump on the train or
whatever I was in the office and they
keep waiting in the office your block I
just wait till you got a spare half an
hour but I'm like I haven't you know
maybe the end of the day comes it's like
six seven o'clock when I believe it in
you just like let's go to the gym now
for now and what happened in a half an
hour crazy
yeah complete madness but how great did
you feel at that was the two weeks that
was the first two weeks in but yeah well
during that during like that that period
that day for instance
I remember being so busy work it was
crazy so stressed out had so much going
on
and it was like crazy on the business
side and it was just not in that place
to work out right at all I couldn't come
work out man I'm so busy I'm so obsessed
and saturated with this in my mind I
can't even think about working out too
busy but then when you forced me
actually that half an hour the escape
and the endorphin released from release
made me then go back to the office
with a new energy and actually I feel
like it helps not hinders my business
yeah because we we you didn't have any
time to think about anything that was
going wrong or anything that was going
right yeah we literally I said to you
we're gonna blitz this half an hour
you've got no time to think this is what
we're doing and we've done it you were
naked you were feeling about the end of
it you were like you were pumped what
happened you won't just happen yeah you
were just you were just pumped but then
you were like I can't believe my fault I
didn't have the energy to do that but
you did yeah and that's that's exactly
why we were working together so often
you don't have the energy to do
something that's when you need to do it
the most if you and if you if you're
really tired you doubt the energy you
need to do it to get the imager yeah
because he will actually give you the
energy yeah because the endorphin
release is real people love to talk
about laughing endorphins the same as
Jim endorphins it's the same thing if
you're the kind of person that gets home
from work and then like flakes on the
sofa then you need to quickly get
yourself even if it's 20 minutes for 10
minutes of fast cardio and yeah he'll
change a whole state
not exactly and that's why my whole
philosophy on the five minute you said
today earlier on which was great doing
five minutes a day every for the whole
month is better than doing one hour a
week in the gym and you're absolutely
right you're doing something every day
for your body your mind your soul and it
is a time to escape like when you're
doing any exercise I generally can't
think of anything else I'm literally in
that moment and I hope when we're doing
things that we're talking about
visualization every time you're working
out you're visualizing the person you
want to be and the more you do that the
more you'll see change I tell you what I
heard you have a small fear see I
haven't been less than 15 to 15 for yeah
like I said ever 15 for is the lightest
weight I've been when we first started
working out I was in the high 60s yeah
says like Shirley 15:11 now I was 50
yeah now I'm about 50 11th years we've
lost wave right with right his next
thing isn't my fear my fear I just can't
physically I kind of can't physically
imagine being in the 14th 13th I just I
can't see it yeah I understand that
though because I a lot of people might
not know I was like 19 stone and I
remember looking in the mirror thinking
to myself am I ever going to change is
am I not gonna be this person anymore
that I see even now sometimes I go and
wake up in the morning I look in the
mirror and I thought wow I actually did
it and this is years later years later I
still feel like that
but the moments when I was in it and I
was fearing that am I ever gonna see
that wait because I remember the same
thing am I gonna see the fourteens I
thought I even went down to the tours at
one point because I went got that self
obsessed with getting my body to a
certain point but what you have to do is
just realize and understand that it's
all the process the more you're
consistent the more you actually just
continue to do what you're doing it will
just happen you don't have to think
about anymore in your situation you
don't have to think about it I have to
think about it so for me that's my job
now I have to look it and go alright
we've been floating at 15 16 15 6 let's
say we're there we float in there for
about two weeks I'm like alright I
needed romantic change I need to shock
his body I need to do something but I
genuinely believe in how I train you and
how you respond to training where
laughing you got no problems
yeah I mean it's just so it's just so
interesting because I'm so glad that
I've got you do it yeah you almost
owning it yeah definitely I'm taking I'm
taking it on board for myself yeah and
it's a pet is a personal know what about
someone what about someone watching this
The Economist is early afford to just
hire a fitness celebrity full-time well
this is why things like apps and for
things like that provided you know I've
got my app and fit freak so if you've
got Sky television you can basically
watch the fit in five shows funny
because I always hate the idea of the
app I mean when you talk about yeah
or whatever like you know but you've
done it but but but I have but sometimes
if you on the weekends or whatever if
it's just some day and you've said to me
or if I can't make it cuz I'm really
busy usually don't go on the app and I
went on the app no no whatever yeah and
I'm gonna own this out and I was
thinking fitting five like come on five
minutes and if it's your audience
afterwards I remember but but you know
what
got the ice fridge to free up yeah so
moany I'm Commissioner freeze disclaimer
there's no ya know there are many made
here people ya know that we're problem
if there was is that see but there's no
one to be made here so got the app
called fit for its or 55 yeah fit freak
series and that five-minute session I
did it and I was absolutely naked and it
was like you were in the room because
you're there
Diane and and I remember thinking
afterwards if I just did that every day
if I just thought the fit freaked out I
just did five minutes every day yeah I
would be so fit just off of that and
that's why I said to you I think every
day would be better than an hour a week
because consistency is king yeah exactly
so doing and with design and how
everyone's body works obviously some
people have really bad injuries they
can't work out and then that the you
need to seek better advice but in
regards to that this is why we created
our group this is why we're available
online nothing stops anyone from sending
a DM asking how do I do this why am I
not gonna tell you it's just it's free
information I'm not gonna say I'm gonna
charge you this and this I can give you
an answer to something by viewing into
depth or something some people need
depth and understanding we're in an age
right now where we've got information
below oh right thank you so much there's
so much information and even on
everything on property I teach property
people's are always all online for free
it's like firstly it's not online for
free but secondly even if it is you have
to filter through so much nonsense yeah
to get the 0.1% you don't know what to
we don't know what to think and what
I've done with you is I've just saw said
I'm just going to tell you what you tell
me everything that I thought about stuff
before I'm just gonna forget it and do
it and stick to stick with the program
how do you think that being fit being
healthy
is it a case of it's really easy as
obvious just eat less exercise more or
is it complex and is there a real
science to it the complexities to it is
individuality and is who you are as a
person your body type how often you work
out what your job is family kids sleep
all these things play a part in your
fitness journey yeah so as you could
have to are giving an example to friends
like spur to females clients that I had
where one had children - children yeah
and the same age one had no children no
dependence at all one's going to the gym
every day and they're like oh you should
come with me just how they get him
babysitting how are they going to find a
babysitter they can't find a babysitter
when they do find a babysitter going the
gym less someone's results are going to
be different based on their lifestyles
yeah and that's how you've got to look
it and that's why it becomes a bespoke
because you've then and that's what
we're doing your lifestyle changes on a
daily basis it's crazy so you'll say
we're training in the morning but then
I'll get a message going no something's
come up
we got to sort something out for the
afternoon unfortunately the luxury that
we have is the fact that unlike call
this is where we're training this is
what we're doing someone else that's it
they're not going to train yeah it's
that simple that used to happen though
the Train how would I get on with a
regular PJ well you could never do it we
were laughing about the other day I said
you how many sessions would you have
counseled by now probably 15 to 20 yeah
just because the flicks there's no flex
most days yeah most ways you'd have to
cancel and they're not gonna get to your
house as early as I'm getting it like is
that they're not gonna be able to do it
if you come out at like 6:00 a.m.
yes exams exfoli and that's because we
need to get it done and then your height
for the rest of the day we've done a day
where I've seen you go from 6 a.m. and
then you're doing a talk at 11:30 at
night yeah I'm like oh my god I know
that's your standard day and I'm like
sitting there like you said falling on
the couch falling over and I'm like this
guy's on stage right now giving a
thousand percent and I'm inspired cuz
I'm like I thought I was tired he's done
a workout the whole day business deals
traveling coming back and then all those
students thousands sitting there and
you're just like a thousand percent
energy 16 hours later
yeah and that's and to me I'm like okay
if he's maintaining this energy
let's bring this energy into training
and that's exactly what we've done yeah
and that's that's you though and that's
where I know that working review is
completely different to working with
someone else
people bring emotional baggage into
training people bring like so much
different types of baggage into their
training but my job is to filter it and
go how can I use that in the session to
motivate them how can I use that to make
you feel empowered to go well this is
how I'm feeling right now how do I then
translate that into exercise and their
life you know with our training it isn't
just about fitness it's all about mental
state it's all about mindset I'm all
staked on mindset where we're at right
now
who we are right now and who were trying
to be tomorrow yeah that's awesome
do you know a lot of people probably
would say like oh he's just gonna say
where but you know what it's been so fun
like I've had so much fun working with
you because every day is not a challenge
it's more of for me it's day of like
this is what we're gonna do is today I'm
excited because I know that you're up
for anything you're up for doing things
that I don't want to do yeah you're like
let's do benefits like we're gonna be
like we're gonna be doing this and he's
like yeah whatever things are we gonna
do and I'm like I'm planning different
Fitness days you're hyped for them so
for me I'm like okay you're challenging
me to do things out of my comfort zone
it's supposed to be their way around so
we're going to teach you crazy stuff
like oh yeah crazy man we're going to
Ibiza yeah we're gonna have a hot week
you know fitness week is and we're gonna
be doing yoga shakrappa latte bringing
all this crazy stuff which is a lot all
these added bonuses like you bring all
these protein bars yeah we don't really
always equip them around or you're like
you just said to me I want to introduce
you just really awesome yoga person I'll
bring around your house yes all this
stuff going on which is just for me
because I mean it keeps you fresh yeah
you know we go to the some of those
noodles too are at a gym session one in
the office your horror group right let's
go let's go and do it we'll hire our
syndicate room in a hotel if I'm
speaking on stage and do stuff we'll
just we'll be a little private room
smash it
we're doing been nervous we've got some
crazy portrays that I can't wait for the
guys to see it's gonna be awesome it's
gonna be awesome
so like I'm really excited how people
get involved in this job we should do we
should do Fitness then I fitness event
or a retreat or some something where we
we involve your best practice in what
you do and combine that with Fitness
people are watching this
there's no because we'll put some
suggestions or I would suggest in my
opinion I think an event would be good
but I also think a retreat like a nice
high end not too many people maybe just
10 20 people but like a week together
yeah something crap but I'm open to
suggestions
yeah I am too I know on the fitness side
and the mindset side were covered yeah
like we're good like between you and me
yeah you're getting nothing about 100%
energy there's a saying that says how
you do anything is how you do everything
and it's like if you're sloppy in
business you're gonna be sloppy with
your fitness if you sloppy with if you
mind
sloppy then you're gonna have sloppy
relationships this is everything and for
me I always neglected my health a little
bit because I was so obsessed with all
the other areas not just business but
you know relationships with with my like
my church faith charity business
finances teaching people YouTube so much
going on which is going so well and then
I thought oh you know what I deserve
this correct I deserve this company I
love this and actually I think that what
I deserve this thing that's gonna be bad
on my body yeah it's actually a
punishment yeah you're absolute and you
know what it took me years to understand
that I would have a really tough week at
work on when I was an analyst at Sky
online and I was working these 12-hour
days and it was just crazy and the first
thing you want to do and you've got a
break is I need to eat something good
but not good as in healthy something bad
that's gonna make me feel good about the
taste and the feeling of being full and
being oh I like just feeling that
feeling when you're sitting on the couch
and you feeling oh I used to love that
feeling but then it turned out I
realize this is a punishment feeling yes
that's a Christmas feeling you only
supposed to feel like that on Christmas
and your birthday yeah no other days
you're not supposed to be able to not
get out of the chair but that that
change for me alias changed everything
cuz when you said to me when a meal
together when I said to you the end of
the meal this is when we just got
started
I said I'm still hungry though and you
said really you said you're still hungry
or you're just not full yeah sounds like
well yeah I'm just not like satisfied
yeah and you said but the thing is when
you eat it's supposed to tide you over
yeah to the next meal I was like I don't
want to eat no like that hides me over I
want to eat and I want to feel for ya
and then you said no because if you feel
full then you're gonna be sluggish yeah
nice thinking alright okay so they over
and then a few I was like okay and this
this monster eating tasty nourishing
food yeah the tides over to the next
meal and then I'm not sluggish I'm just
nice and Mitchell that was a game
changer for me yeah I remember it was
difficult cuz I member saying to you
you're eating what was it two meals a
day you were having yeah big ones
massive because that was to give you
enough cuz I have a lot of time yeah so
just get breakfast and then I'd go out
for out of a big lunch and snacks and
then bang go back into it like allies
like a lion yeah wanted a massive me I
mean in the evening
I'd get home I have a few snacks then
about 8 p.m. a of course you deserve it
but what you were doing was punishment
and you weren't allowing your body to
even how you gonna how's your food gonna
digest if you guys sleep yeah so eating
like a free and a half thousand calorie
meal before you go into bed yeah how is
it possible to digest that food you're
actually using that food as energy for
the next day but the first thing you've
done the next day was you had your
protein bars in the morning or you've
got a big breakfast somewhere at one of
the hotels and then you're just piling
food on top of food yeah so what we did
was we just had a conversation and
micromanage to that in a way it made you
realize have this an hour and a half to
two hours later have this and now enough
to say like have this so by the time you
were like I want to eat it was time to
eat yes and you know larger self / yes
as well I've lost quite in the past but
it's usually been because I've got on a
strict diet or like a alright I'm gonna
juice so I'm gonna fast I'm gonna do
this I will start myself and all means
to which you know that you're not going
to sustain it you've got to change the
way you think about food change the way
to think about health and fitness change
the way you know I think that's it fall
in love with the process yeah right now
we're living in a false fitness economy
where's everybody and a lot of the
Instagram social media there's some
great things online but there's some
terrible things online like you'll see
people just depicting this is what
Fitness looks like a nine pack six seven
five percent body fat if someone will
see that as thinking that's being fit
whereas I know exactly what that person
eats to what they have a day in order
for them to maintain that you can't do
that for your life it's just not
sustainable and that's why people have
offseason and then they're bulking
they're cutting it's just not something
that's healthy for you you look great
for a small period of time I've done it
and it's just not sustaining what I
don't I love food food doesn't love me
for me to eat badly all the time but for
me to have those lovely nights out where
you want to go to dinner with your wife
when you want to have dinner with the
family they're not so often enough to
where it's gonna affect me physically to
put on the weight I lost so my whole
teachings in what we're doing is for you
to have fun with your family oh it's
just son's birthday there's cake why
shouldn't you have any cake but you what
you need to do is not have all the other
trimmings that come with Hawaii but
enjoy that with your kids let them show
them that you have got the good habits
to where they know you can have that but
you do know that here we're gonna have
to work out tomorrow yeah that's what my
daughter says all the time when we eat
something and like it for instance it
was national pizza day the other day and
she said straight after the pizza we're
gonna have to do a workout now I didn't
tell her that she just knows I
put it in a psychological state of mind
that's what you need to do is have a
balance it's so important because your
kid - I mean I've got you've got two
kids I've got two kids they my kids are
very young but they they do copy yeah
and if you are not taking your health
seriously or not taking your life
seriously yeah this is my home this body
- disrespect it to overeat to not
exercise to not work out to not nourish
it you know that is a bad example where
they yeah and I'm not judging anybody
listen I've neglected my house but I
just for me I just thought do I really
want my kids and that's my kids but also
enough said this to you before everyone
that watches me on YouTube it'll know do
I really want to send out a message to
say it's okay to not take your health
seriously I don't wanna send that
message people because a bad message but
I want to inspire people in every aspect
but what are you saying that you've just
taken that on board in a way where it
takes people years to have that self
reflection like it took me such a long
time to really understand exactly what
you've just said and really go I'm
actually ruining myself I'm actually not
doing any benefits for me nor to anybody
around me and the fact that you've got
there that's what transpired into us
working together because I knew you were
there if you weren't there you'd have
canceled all of our sessions I would
have been literally on payroll without
even working you out and that wouldn't
have been right so you hold yourself
accountable I'm not taking any credit
other than the fact that I'm making sure
that you're there but you're the one
that turns up you're the one that laces
up ultimately you create your own life
you've gotta take responsibility but
then you but then so with me on the
training as well a team people finance
they're responsible for their own
success all their own failure exactly
then I will be a tool and assist them in
there so dude it's all some thanks for
coming on and I think I need to do more
of these I'm having maybe once a month
or once every other month or at least
once a quarter we need to do something
there's a vlog as well that went up on
last Thursday which was talking which
was like a vlog showing the fitness how
I lost a stone in the moat
I recommend checking out finder on
youtube check out Marvin Marvin
Ambrosius yes awesome guy mr. legend and
did I really appreciate your support man
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]